sapete che io vi porto la qualità oggi
hanno fatto un gioco chiamato the bench
la panchina ora possiamo intuire la
qualità perché vediamo un vecchio con un
piccione in testa un cane che sta
scodinzolando davanti a uno dog e senza
mangiarlo quindi è un fantasy un tasso
che rovista nell'immondizia lanciando
cartacce una pizza sulla panchina è un
altro piccione dubstep
i testi sono tron food del tasto
sinistro change woods mezzo attacco del
cane da so che la mia vita consiste nel
non essere beccato agli animali perchè
doveva abbastanza cibo
tieni c'è anche l'energia se siete
lancio troppi non va bene bellissimo
la pizza tieni tea regalo la pizza
questa qua fatta da cracco direttamente
questa tua grazie molto bello sto
gianluca poi anche difenderci
oddio oddio aspetta no volevo aprire il
menu un attimo per capire i tasti e di
niente vi si è chiuso puoi dare le
scoppole agli animali ok del cipe e come
ho fatto prima
eccolo perfetto però poi farlo una volta
ogni tanto non per farlo sempre chiari
pezzo di pane per te vieni 1 dog per te
cane
oddio hot dog e pin ex tutti e due bravi
perfetto levati nelle balle finale vale
eccolo peggio ancora no ragazzi
incredibile agli ami fai male non mi
toccare porco demonio perché mi toccano
i tanti poi imprendo danno ragazzi
questo gioco è incredibile ringraziare i
creatori che tra l'altro lo hanno fatto
mi pare durante la quarantena
nella 40 in jam stiamo centrando cestino
in una maniera
e veramente incredibile io comunque sono
veramente orgoglioso che oggi il mondo
videoludico noi come in eventi sforni
capolavori quindi pensate di andare da
voi
dai dai dai voi stessi di dieci anni fa
che dite chissà come saranno i
videogiochi tra dieci anni ecco qua beh
sì sono i giochi tra dieci anni ecco a
voi ragazzi tutto per voi scatolette
pizza quello che volete
non mi sorprende questo gioco abbia
vinto la jam tra l'altro perché mi pare
che siamo né pilotati e si vede se lo
merita anche l'altro presissimo quanto
possa durare io in sta facendo qua
perché immagino che prima o poi diventi
un casino tipo lo sono tuttora la magia
pizza sicure schizzinoso ma inizia
nemmeno mai non sono vegani top nulla
con i vegani anche non pensateci dovere
altri cinque tasti in platino come ti
permetti fai schifo allora aspetta
aspetta ecco bravo creativa le palle
anche tu la pizza bull dog su titoli
alle palle anche se ci avevi cibo fa
niente ok tieniteli vieni ti ritieni
prego prego prego prego prego melli
ragazzi quanto mi piace sempre è fatto
veramente bene ma posso centrare un
cestino non si può centrare il cestino
purtroppo che strano peccato che sarà
impegnato per farlo top tieniti regalo
basta
mangiate tutti porco demonio ayami fate
male porca vacca avete rotto le balle e
mi fate due giorni vi fate male aiuto lo
so diventa di sostenibile aiuto aspetta
tutto ciò dagli animali a spalanca sino
qua non è che posso andare a tutta la
vita madonna di dio tanto due minuti e
mezzo sta durando e tanto è cavalcabili
rete toglie dalle balle tutti quanti
perfetto pezzo di pane pezzo di pane
pezzo di parate ok you are dead a
sopravvivere minuti per vincere 246 ho
fatto dai ero arrivato alla fine
sopravvitto dei minuti ma dai non avevo
capito sta roba è proviamoci di nuovo
ecco non mi conviene lanciare il cibo
prima in modo che quando arrivano ce
l'hanno già
no perché scompare dopo un po figo
quindi poco ci hanno pensato tutto
signori e signori e sport alle iene alle
volte fanno dei servizi dove prendono
per il culo chi fa e sport della serie v
ma questo quadagna giocando alla
playstation chiusa giochi a fifa io
gioco a vi fa la guadagni giocando alla
playstation a fifa
fatevi vedere questo guadagno facendo
questa roba questa cosa dovrebbe dare
più fastidio
non so credo e poi video tra l'altro non
ho capito che ci metto qui tempo a
spazzare gli animali il canale da
mangiare quindi effettivamente vi
conviene vi conviene di più david a
mangiare che altro e poi spreca un sacco
di energia perché poi per lanciare il
cibo io sono un bacio e quindi spreco un
sacco di energia non è neanche facile
viene allora basta abbaiare top mi
regalo tutto serve per temporeggiare in
realtà la botta che donna tanto
aspetta aspetta altro che sono arrivate
a metà senza prendere danno è quindi
ottimo ragazzi o più così aspetta
aspetta aspetta perfetto che è stato io
escono dai cespugli che comunque ragazzi
noi ridendo e scherzando però il mio
cane fa uguale cioè nel senso quando
mangiamo a tavola siamo il mio cane
identico noi che campionato l'ha
lanciata sala il mio cane è uguale pd io
sono talmente skill ha visto gioco che
riuscirò a secondo tentativo perché io
lo faccio col mio cane tutte le sere la
stessa cosa poi arrivano i cani interi
vicini
sono già stilato ero già fatto tutorial
tanto ho detto che avrei vinto quindi
probabilmente morirò tra un secondo ok
ragazzi dovete stare calmi che questa
vita di ingestibile perfetto grazie
molto gentile anche te grazie tieni non
mi hanno colpito neanche una volta i tre
minuti
ottimo ora che non l'ho detto dopo
effetto sta diventando in gestire
aspetta pezzo di morgan un attimo
ragazzi vi stanno uccidendo alla fine
aiuto non ci credo vi sta riuscendo alla
fine è impossibile arrivare a tre minuti
mi ammazzano e non grosso siete troppi
parco demonio la faccio
ma ti prego decidere mangiarci cascati
333 mancano tre secondi un video sono
talmente skill ha visto gioco che
riuscirò al secondo tentativo degli sci
vostok 1 100 tv io a tutti insieme
perché mentre aspetta
ero talmente vicino alla vittoria che
gioco si è sentito di darmi la vittoria
grazie
sono morto di nuovo porco dei vari
maledizione alla fine proprio di vedere
se non ti toccano fino alla fine non
importa perché l'ha finita ammazzano
comunque infattibile perché poi comunque
io vorrei vecchi il vecchio che sta il
cantiere e fa i punti osservando in base
a quanti cantieri osservi fi punti ma
perché secondo me è un'ottima soluzione
lo propongo per la prossima 40 in jam se
volete farlo ragazzi io cantieri dei
cantieri osservi più punti file non è lo
sapessi sviluppare videogiochi sarebbe
il mio primo è passato che cosa è
successo lì è passato un patto dalle
nulla è più stato un cane ok beta
aspetta chi sta diventando già complica
versi minuto e mezzo
diventa impossibile perché vi giuro che
già adesso è difficile vi non faccio
sembra difficile ma è difficile già
adesso allora ok ok ok ok ok a conosco
la pizza lì a posto quella buona il dog
giani mentre sta diventando impossibile
dico ok perfetto due minuti ragazzi
l'ultimo minuto ragazzi per la gloria
per l'italia per il mio paese per le
iene dai dai ragazzi dai prossimi se non
freni che ha magari è impossibile è
impossibile possibile possibile
possibile che sia cosi e possibile aiuto
15 secondi 15 secondi kama kama dai che
ti sfido ce l'ho fatto secondi ci credo
non mi hanno toccato stavolta da capire
problemi e sport markt 99 animali fidati
tra l'altro ieri mancavano l'arrivo a
cena pro gamer degli indici dei ragazzi
sopra vi sia piaciuto questo era
dall'europa agli hai mai al parco
simulator mentre sei un vecchio
dimenticato cosa che devo dire sì a
docenti nicoli animali da te dire
mangiare un bacio c al prossimo video
beh ragazzi
[Musica]